first of all hand claps for the
nomination
how you feeling feel good man i i feel
good it's you know i've been saying this
this whole time but
a lot of times it's hard for me to
accept praise for my work because i
always feel like i can do better and i
can do more but this one is special
because i'm nominated with a lot of my
friends a lot of the homies so
it feels good it's a great category
right you got marseille
mile storm i was telling miles earlier
this really is like the foundation of
the future so it's good to see
a category like this with you all in it
it's interesting it's like
i want i wonder if what we're going to
be doing in 10 years and looking back
and like hey we're all
nominated together you know i usually
ask actors
um if they have like a message to their
younger selves
but for you do you have a message to
your older self
that maybe when you're older you want to
look back and remember about
how you are in this time and what you're
doing right now
message to my older self i would say uh
stay focused stay focused and don't let
you know there's a lot of noise and
distractions
going on constantly um but you know just
stay focused and make sure that
you and remember why you decided to get
in this industry in the first place and
remember where your passion is
and your love for the art is so yeah
just just continue doing what you're
doing but
don't let all the noise uh get in your
way usually
actors that start young like yourself
they say well i got into it for fun and
i kind of found my passion
for acting is that how you started
in a way yeah yeah because i started
acting when i was uh
in the second grade so of course you
know second grade i'm not thinking about
any career or anything like that you
know
second grade the play i was doing plays
at my
at my school and it was just the thing
to do eventually
uh i guess it was when i got into high
school
is when i was like wait i kind of miss
doing that thing and then as soon as i
immediately
started doing it again i was like okay
this is like
for real this is something we want to do
so i'm going to put my all towards it so
yeah i never even thought about it like
that but i guess it was fun and then
turned into a passion what does a
virtual bet awards look like
at your house what do you do what kind
of background do you have like
virtual pt awards it looks like mom
cooking in the kitchen
helping her out man i love to cook i'm
helping her out and you know
we're not doing it up for anybody we're
just chilling on the couch you know i
love it
only in the hand you know but we having
a good time it's family time uh it's
been a tradition in our family to watch
the bt award so we're gonna keep doing
it okay so do you have like a thank yous
thought about if you were to win like
you know how
um we see the guys at their homes when
they're drafted
in the league and then all the family
runs in it's like a big celebration
that's why it's in my head
i have not thought about it at all like
with no attention towards it whatsoever
but you know i'm sure i'm coming up with
something on the fly
uh you know it would be absolutely an
honor but
no not not on my mind i gotcha
you know you talked about how special
this nomination is for you
and you know partly because of the
material actually probably mostly
because of the material
and the conversation that when they see
us had us having
and now that we're in this time and
space there's even been a rejuvenation
of people watching this
connecting to this piece of work
connecting to this art
what is your feeling about that right
now considering where we are as a
country
i i would say that it's bittersweet
because you know we
when they see us dropped a year ago um
and you know as much as we'd like to say
that we've made progress and learned
from
watching this uh you know it's
entertaining but it's also very
educational uh
film uh unfortunately you know we're
still in the same circumstances
as a country but it also gives me a lot
of hope
because people are watching it now and
from watching it are getting inspired
and even outside of just the the film
itself but
you know are getting inspired and are
truly pushing towards change and
and it's just a remarkable thing to
witness in real time i can't wait to you
know look back in 20 years and be like
wow we really lived through that and and
hopefully think you know things have
changed and things are for the better
you're giving me goosebumps asante
you're you're giving me goosebumps you
know
we we did fall in love with you for such
a raw performance
and when they see us and it it hit so
many of us right in the heart
what can we take from that piece of art
about our justice system
and about how we view black bodies and
especially
black bodies of young men i think
standing
in your truth that is one thing that all
five of those boys now men
did that got them to the place that they
that they are now you know standing in
their truth while everything that they
had to go through was hard
and it was you know it was not uh fair
when you stick by your truth and and you
know that what you
that what people are saying about you is
not true at the end of the day you are
going to come out on top you are going
to come out
uh successful so make sure that you know
everything that you are a part of
uh it represents you um in the best of
in the best of ways
and that's why we call them the
exonerated five thank you sir
good luck to you proud of you brother
thank you so much